but it's all around us we're using it
the whole time and I wonder Catherine if
you could start us with that what does
AI look like in the world right now so I
think it's a very good point that AI is
a really ill-defined term and I don't
think it has you know a real concrete
definition of what it is and so the best
I can come up with is computers trying
to sort of emulate some sort of human
intelligence and obviously we're a very
long way from and hopefully we'll get to
that question of how closer are we to
human intelligence but we're on the path
to computers that are becoming more and
more intelligent and I think if we look
at some of the ways that technology is
used right now in the world we can see
some real good examples of artificial
intelligence and how it's used you
mentioned Alexa obviously that is a I
think I think a very nice example of how
AI is working at the moment and if you
have Alexa or you've talked to Siri or
any of these other virtual assistants
you might have a sense of how good the
technology is you know it can listen to
you it can understand certain things it
does a lot of smart stuff behind the
scenes but also it has some limitations
I'm not going to say that it's solved um
conversation and so you get a sense of
these sort of limitations and potential
if you look at things that are out there
in the real world and this technology is
being used in all sorts of other places
as well that you may or may not know
about there's a very interesting project
I'm working on with the company which is
about dubbing videos from one language
into another using synthetic speech
using AI to do that that dabbing and
these are places where the technology is
now really getting good enough despite
having some limitations it's getting
good enough to be used in these sort of
real world scenarios
so I think yeah taking a look at where
AI is used right now is a great
introduction to how it works we've got
to be careful I've just been told we
can't say Alexa because people watching
back home uh it's not going haywire so
that was the last time no saying hey we
know what her name is and we'll talk
about the gendered nature of that as
well actually
um Chris that's a great summary of where
we are now um but it is in all sorts of
builds what do you you see a lot of it
especially on the really cutting edge
side what are you most excited by in
terms of the applications of AI well I
think we've seen huge advances even just
in the last couple of years or so and
it's sort of become ubiquitous so there
are many many places that AI shows up in
our daily lives that we don't know about
I mean I think one you know Arthur Clark
the science fiction writer one said you
know the the best Technologies ones that
disappear into the into the background
they help you in your daily lives you're
not aware of it so it's just all sorts
of things like you know opening your
phone with your face or translating from
one language to another on a website or
just many many examples of this but I do
have real sense that the and I've been
in the field for about 35 years I mean
we've the field has been called machine
learning that I've been in and rather
than artificial intelligence but it's
really a machine learning has really
become the dominant approach to
artificial intelligence and really just
in the last year or two we've seen just
extraordinary advances to the point
where
um I think the next few years in
particular will see some very rapid
changes I think coming back to
Catherine's you know excellent
description of artificial intelligence
is a slippery fish it's very hard to
Define I think there are many different
axes to intelligence different kinds of
intelligence uh and and some of these in
terms of artificial intelligence
progressing very rapidly and others are
making slower progress others have
almost been solved in effect
um so really the way research progresses
it doesn't progress uniformly on all
fronts there are certain areas that are
very exciting the field that I'm
particularly excited about is the impact
of machine learning and artificial
intelligence on the Natural Sciences on
chemistry physics biology this is a very
exciting theme it's such an exciting
field that I've actually pivoted my
career started a new role building up a
global team in this space because we
think that machine learning will have a
big impact on our ability to to model
and simulate the world with with many
applications in in drug Discovery and
understanding human disease in
discovering new materials particularly
for sustainability new battery materials
new photovoltaics catalysts ways of
capturing carbon directly from there and
so on so that's the field that I'm
particularly excited about right now and
Anna what are you looking at and
thinking wow that's interesting that's
changing my understanding
there has been enormous progress in
machine learning and AI I've been
involved on the edges of the field for
20 years as a neuroscientist with a deep
interest in machine learning and AI
um but what's what's striking it's like
what you said Catherine that it's
there's lots of very specific
applications out there and then if you
look at what AI systems in my
understanding are still not very good at
they are the kinds of things that we do
associate with specifically human kinds
of intelligence things like generalizing
to new situations very quickly learning
things from very small amounts of data
we don't need to be trained on an
internet's worth of cat pictures to
recognize a cat as a human being
there's knowing why we know what we know
now we know something we can say I have
that I have confidence in this judgment
we have insight into our into our
knowledge and then there's the the sort
of guiding a behavior yeah sure we have
self-driving cars and drones that fly
around but as much progress as there has
been in things like playing go or
solving equations in Natural Science
chances we still don't have the kind of
AI that can control bodies in the way
that you know we often used to see in in
science fiction and it may be that we
don't need these things maybe this is
not the goal maybe this is not the
future of AI but that raises the
interesting question of how much AI can
tell us about the human brain that for
me that's that's the frontier that I'm
interested in what can these new
generations of machine learning and
artificial intelligence models reveal
about cognition thought in humans in
other animals and ultimately of course
this big question of why for for us
there is consciousness why it feels like
anything to be this complex biological
machine that we are and I think AI is
very very far from shedding much useful
light on that question we still need to
solve that question by the end of the
panel though so
hop to it I mean that's really it feels
like you know artificial intelligence I
think it conditions us maybe to think of
a mirror version of human intelligence
but actually we've got a new type of
intelligence this is you know the a
words and the s word it does something
that humans don't need to do and they do
it in very different ways
um because you mentioned that the last
two years been the sort of Cambrian
explosion of uh new ideas and really
really coming along and Catherines as
well what's been driving that we've had
Peaks and troughs with AI research the
AI Winters where funding dries up and
it's very unfashionable to even talk
about Ai and then these boom towns boom
time sorry it seems like we're in a boom
time what's been driving that
I think there are a couple of things
actually a couple of discoveries that
we've made in the field in the last two
years that are quite transformational
um the first one has to do with scale so
I I switched from physics into machine
learning into AI about 35 years ago
because I was excited about the idea of
machines that could learn
um it was probably a little naive back
then because we thought that uh uh we
call them neural networks these models
that we build in the computer they have
um back then hundreds or thousands of
these adjustable parameters they're
rather superficially rather like the
synapses in between neurons in the brain
and they adjust as the system learns and
we thought a neural network with a
thousand of these adjustable parameters
was a big network but what we discovered
in in the last couple of years or so is
as you go to very large systems new
properties emerge new capabilities
emerge so um we have colleagues in at a
company called open AI who a couple of
years ago plotted a graph and on the
horizontal axis was uh was time from the
1960s up to about 2020 and on the
vertical axis was how much compute do
you to train the state-of-the-art in
machine learning and it was it was on a
what we call a logarithmic scale so
basically when you see a straight line
what it means is the amount of compute
was doubling every two years or so what
that meant was the field was benefiting
like everything else was benefiting from
Moore's Law the the doubling and compute
power every couple of years but then
since about 2012 something remarkable
has happened again it's a straight line
but it's much steeper what it means is
that the amount of compute needed to
train the biggest models has been
doubling not every two years but about
every three and a half months so it
means it's about a factor of 10 per year
and that has continued to hold and with
every factor of 10 we're seeing new new
capabilities emerge that didn't exist at
the previous factor of 10. so that's
been one sort of breakthrough now
Anna was talking about you know all the
data that you need to train these
systems of course as you go up in a
factor of 10 you need 10 times as much
compute 10 times as much data but the
other discovery that we've made is is
what's called transfer learning the idea
that A system can learn to solve one
problem it then becomes much faster at
learning a new one so I'll give you a
simple example if you
um you find a sort of a blob on your
skin and you're wondering you know is
that just an annoying little thing or is
that is that some sort of cancer that's
going to spread and kill me and of
course you'd go to a dermatologist and
they would they would look at this and
and uh and diagnose it and so people
were wondering could you
um could you take a photograph of this
and from the photograph that a machine
tell the difference now the problem
there is there aren't there may be
hundreds of thousands of examples of
this but from a machine learning point
of view there really isn't very much
data and so a team of researchers
tackled this by taking another machine
Learning System that had been trained on
a very large data set of things like you
know bicycles and cats and dogs and
mushrooms and so on it and they took
that big trained system and then just
retrained the last little layer on this
new task using a much smaller amount of
data and and it achieves uh human level
performance on that particular task
comparable to a team of professional
dermatologists so this is a very stated
result so what it means is that as these
systems go to very large scale they can
become much broader because throughout
much of the history of AI we've
developed a system over here for speech
recognition another system over here for
natural language understanding or
something and they've been rather
separate and it's what we're seeing now
is a convergence of different
Technologies into a single in a single
model so it's made this a very very
interesting time to be in the field yeah
that's really exciting I'm just a
reminder
um before getting you Catherine um
please submit your questions by scanning
the QR code but also vital that you add
your name to it otherwise we can't find
you to ask the question and it will get
asked but you won't get the glory of
having your name associated with it and
if you're on Twitter the hashtag is
hashtag Big Ideas live 22. I mean that
does sound incredibly exciting the way
you've done it uh you've the way you've
told it there
um but there's sort of talk a very very
large systems and new properties
emerging at the same time being used in
very vital ways as you say cancer
identification but you know algorithms
are used in all sorts of important
decisions in our lives and you know in
the states and some places they're used
in sentencing criminals things like that
how worried
ignoring the Terminator question which
would do but how worried were you now
about regulating this sometimes it seems
like a black box how do we open that up
and make sure it's being fair
um we're not making the wrong decisions
so I think you're right it is a bit of a
black box at the moment to be able to
see inside some of these AI machine
learning systems and understand how
they're arriving at the decision that
they're making and that is a really
difficult problem to solve and I don't
think that we have the tools and
techniques to be able to look inside
that now so we can't for example ask on
your own network to justify a decision
about say sentencing in the same way
that you could ask a human judge to
justify that decision and so that's one
area that I think we really need to
spend some effort into developing tools
and techniques to look inside that black
box and figure out but one of the things
that we can do and we should be doing is
looking at how these systems work in the
real world so judging whether they are
exhibiting bias against particular
groups by judging how they're working on
on real people's data
um there are many examples of how face
recognition systems and speech
recognition systems end up performing
worse on particular demographics
particularly groups of people just
because of the way that they've been
trained or the the sort of data that
they've already seen is not
representative of the real world and so
we really need to be spending time and
effort so taking a speech recognition
system and making sure that it works
across a range of accents with the
similar kind of accuracy or looking at
face recognition systems and being sure
that they are actually performing well
for different people because when these
systems are used in the world and they
become part of everybody's day-to-day
life obviously it holds people back if
these systems are treating them
differently to to other groups of people
so that's a real area that I think is
receiving quite a lot of attention right
now people are trying to understand how
neural networks are working and we're
making progress in how to evaluate them
for for actual real well problems when
we talk about
emerging properties as well
um some people would argue that
Consciousness is an emerging property of
a breath are we ever going to realize I
know when a machine might become
sentient do you think that's even
possible and be how would we know
the answer to the first question is it
even possible I think the honest answer
is that nobody really knows the reason
nobody really knows for a machine is
that nobody really knows even for other
animals other human beings even I cannot
be 100 sure that you are conscious
though I think you are I'm trying and
it's it's it's a unique problem in
science to try in some sense we know and
we've known for for hundreds of
thousands of years that Consciousness
depends on the brain and the body in a
fundamental way you change the brain you
change your conscious experience
yet unlike other problems in biology and
indeed all of science Consciousness is a
private subjective experience I can't
put a conscious experience on the table
and we can all look at it and agree I
can tell you about my experience but
it's it's essentially indirect and
that's what that's some people have said
this means we can't even address the
problem with the tools of science and
philosophy I think that's entirely wrong
we can it's just that there are going to
be some limits on the data that we can
get now
we are learning an increasing amount
about what the basis of Consciousness is
in the human brain which parts of the
brain are necessary or not necessary
um but
we still don't know the answer to a
fundamental question which is does
consciousness
depends on the stuff that something is
made of you and I are made out of carbon
we have biological neurons we have wet
swear rather than the hardware does that
matter now there's one school of thought
that says it doesn't if you program a
computer the right way if the next
generation of machine learning
architectures is is trained in enough
data and the next thing that might
emerge might be awareness but there's no
real good reason to assume that's the
case some things
if you it doesn't matter what it's made
of a computer that plays chess really
plays chess but other things the
material matters like a computer
simulation of a weather forecast that we
all use too it doesn't actually get wet
and windy inside the computer that
simulates the weather and Consciousness
and Consciousness is not the same thing
as intelligence and I think this is a
crucial distinction to make because it
so often said like
not by anyone here of course but in the
wider public that that Consciousness is
some function of intelligence that once
AI crosses some threshold then the
lights come on and it's not only going
to be smart it's going to be sentient
but I think this is
comes from a place of human
exceptionalism we think we're really
special as humans we think we're
intelligent and we know we're conscious
so we think that things go together but
Consciousness we should Define it
actually I mean Consciousness is really
any kind of experience whatsoever it
feels like something to be a conscious
system
but you can an experience of pain or of
seeing color
is is enough you know you don't have to
have complex cognition going on uh in
order to be be conscious so there's no
real good reason to expect that simply
ratcheting up intelligence is going to
make an AI system conscious
and just by observing apparently
intelligent Behavior I don't think it's
a reliable signature of whether the
thing is conscious and I think we can be
misled here systems can give us a strong
intuition that there's a conscious mind
there when there's just the whirring of
algorithms we'll come back to that it's
a really interesting point which ties
into a later talk Chris we should check
first whether you do you have any
sentient robots up in Cambridge locked
away in the lab and you just haven't
told people about it well actually I
love Daniel's answer right this panel is
discussing two different things I think
one is the the ability to create
machines that have certain information
processing and reasoning capabilities
which is a fantastically exciting field
with uh enormous practical implications
actually addressing some of the
society's most challenging problems
right now and with potential for
um the wrong things to happen I think
Catherine gave a lovely description of
how we need the right guard rails in in
how we create and deploy this technology
and on the other hand this fascinating
impression of Consciousness which is a
person's subjective experience I
experience Consciousness I'm guessing
you experience something similar because
you know we're all broadly the same
within the same species and so on and
and this tremendously difficult question
of whether knowing what a machine
experience is whether it experience is
anything I think that's one of the one
of the toughest problems in science in a
way it's just it's very hard to know
even where to get started I think just
separating out those two I think is
actually very helpful for the discussion
and not conflating them
why do you think we have this obsession
with wanting to have conscious machines
as Sarah James is saying it's such a
Trope of Science Fiction you know some
brilliant films about it some bad films
about it as well it's something we
clearly feel the need to see in the
world why is that Catherine I think
you're right it is a Trope of Science
Fiction and we we want to emulate
ourselves somehow in what we do and so
people are driven to build replicas of
people build technology which is like us
but if you look back over time you see
that it's been a constant thread through
the history of technology that people
have wanted to assign human agency to
technology even to other inanimate
objects you'll hear people talking about
how their you know their TV is annoyed
with them or something like that we
assign human human properties to
technology into other things there's a
famous example of a chatbot which was
built back in the 60s called Eliza which
was very simple chat but it was a
therapist
um it had some canned answers so you
tell it problem and it might say can you
tell me more about that or sometimes it
would flip your your question back on
you so you might say I'm feeling unhappy
and it would say can you tell me why
you're feeling unhappy very simple
responses
um and the the creator of this program
wanted to show how stupid computers were
but but people did believe that Eliza
had human-like intelligence and and the
Creator was very surprised by this that
he could I had the opposite effect
and and I think that this trend has sort
of carried on through people are really
Keen to assign human properties to
computers especially when they're using
language and other human-like animations
and and that sort of thing and did you
want to yeah just to come in briefly on
this I think you're absolutely right
that we do project agency and intention
and also Consciousness onto things very
readily you know onto our pets onto
Tamagotchi yeah exactly those things we
used to have but this question of why do
we feel like this is something we need
in our world in our lives I think really
does need to be interrogated because
just as much as we don't know what it
would take to build a machine that has
experience we also don't know what it
wouldn't take and we might do it by
accident we might not know if we've done
it and if if this happens it would be an
ethical catastrophe because soon as
something can have experience
we have an ethical obligation to it to
minimize its potential suffering
and if we don't even know the criteria
by which to establish whether that's
even a possibility we're in really
really deep Waters so just building
something because it sounds cool and
you've seen it in science fiction and
you want to be at The Cutting Edge of
this pivotal moment in in human history
is a really really terrible idea so I I
think that these
goals of building actually conscious AI
are are just wrong we should not be
trying to do that but having said that
there's a sense in which the two things
are not maybe completely separate
Consciousness and intelligence because
the kinds of things back to where we
started the discussion and the kinds of
things that a lot of current AI is not
very good at
seem to be the kinds of things that we
are good at and that we associate with
Consciousness it's like we're very good
at generalizing to new situations we're
very good at reflecting on our own
decisions
metacognition these kinds of things we
know what we think about we're very good
at integrating large amounts of
information very quickly these are the
sorts of things that that experiments in
Neuroscience psychology have shown are
closely associated with human
consciousness so I think there's a case
for building machines that have some of
the functions that we associate with
Consciousness but that's very different
from the goal of trying to build a
machine that feels which I think is a
really bad idea but I but I think just
just pushing back a little there I think
there's a risk of saying computers can't
do X Y and Z because next year they'll
be able to do X maybe or maybe the year
after it's Y and I think there's a risk
that humans become the peace that's left
over the machines haven't yet done and
the reality of AIS exists today it's
actually completely reverse I think you
commented earlier that there's a
complementarity between machines do and
what um and what the human brain does
and the actual original question about
Hollywood movies there's a reason the
Hollywood movies depict Killer Robots
because they've got to keep it being
entertained for two hours right and if
you take I mean I'll just give you an
example of AI in practice we've
developed a system called inner eye
which was actually deployed at Adam
Brooks Hospital in Cambridge we
developed in in partnership with their
with their clinicians
um and it's uh it's used to do radiation
therapy planning so somebody has a solid
tumor and they need radiation therapy
you need to know very precisely where
the tumor is in three-dimension
to treat it with radiation and the way
that's done conventionally in most
places now is the you have a 3D body
scan and the radiation oncologist goes
through this layer by layer and marks
the boundary of the at the boundary of
the tumor can take 20 minutes for a
simple case can take several hours if
it's metastasized there are multiple
tumors
um so what inner eye does is it it does
that automatically and presents a a
proposal for this three-dimensional
segmentation we call it to the radiation
oncologist who then can go through and
check and make any corrections and
alterations to the radiation oncologist
is still doing this this segmentation
but instead of taking several hours they
can just take a couple of minutes to
check a proposal most of the time
they're not making many changes